tonight there is however cautious hope
of new gun control legislation following
the recent school massacre in yuvaldi
texas
speaking at the white house press
briefing today hollywood actor matthew
mcconaughey who grew up in uvalde he
called on lawmakers to put their
differences aside and to take action
take a listen
we are in a window of opportunity right
now that we have not been in before
a window where it seems like real change
real change can happen
this should not be a partisan issue
there is not a democratic or republican
value in one single act of these
shooters it's not
but people in power
have failed to act so we're asking you
and i'm asking you will you please ask
yourselves
can both sides rise above
can both sides see beyond the political
problem at hand and admit that we have a
life preservation problem on our hands
we start
[Music]
by making
the loss of these lives
matter
i want to go down to our washington
correspondent stephen simons he has
reported he was just in uvalde texas
stefan you've covered a lot of mass
shootings in the u.s each time we hear
that something
must be done today marks two weeks since
the uvalde school massacre
i mean is it going to be different this
time and i'm wondering you know having a
movie star standing on
on the podium at the white house i'm not
too sure that that's going to move any
of those senators in congress
yeah and you're rightfully so doubtful
about this no doubt this was a very
emotional plea
uh from mr mckenna and uh carnegie in
here in in dc um that's not normally a
stage uh you know he's
only talking to actors
receiving awards or what have you but
definitely not to the washington press
corps anyhow
uh you're
you're right uh it's uh there is hope
there is hope even
with politicians here even with the
pundits with the experts with uh
journalists who cover this a lot that
there will be
some progress made and when i say some
progress i mean baby steps because
everybody knows despite his emotional
pleas today at the white house press
briefing uh there
will not be radical reform or any tie
any kind of real reform of the current
gun law on the federal level
that's not going to happen i
i think i believe i'm afraid of
we know that president biden he has
spelled out what he wants to see as you
say the political reality
um probably will not allow that so what
are you hearing in terms of what is most
likely
well so most likely is that
senators and this is all about the
importance of the senate right
if senators republicans and democrats
can decide on something and it looks
like there's a negotiation team
at the works every day for the last few
days a week or so
and they probably be able to get a
compromise on in
incentivizing uh states to adopt or pass
red flag laws and let me read this here
so make sure i make no mistake also that
for example the potential waiting time
or period for 18 to 20 or 21 year olds
will be increased before they can
actually get a weapon they can buy it
but then they don't receive it they have
to wait a little longer maybe investment
in
more health mental health care and an
improvement in school safety so that's
all the nice stuff but what's not on the
table is for example increasing the age
um
to buy air 15 style weapons
from 18 to 21 year olds not gonna happen
probably ban on an assault rifle not
happening universal background checks
also not in the books and restricting
the magazines you know those
high-powered magazines you can 50 70 60
bullets in there
that's also pretty much off the table so
there you go that's what you have so let
me let me throw something nice let me
throw something at you here as you
coming from germany living in the united
states how does it strike you on that in
the united states
you have to be 21 to buy a beer
but they you've got senators who don't
want you to have to be 21 to buy
a weapon that was designed to kill as
many people in as short a time as
possible
yeah uh yeah
what can i say it is when you if you
look uh from the outside uh at this you
are just baffled i think uh and you
shake your head and in disbelief
you know you have to have a fishing
license in most all of the states all 50
states
and you do not have to have a license to
carry or purchase a gun
you can drive when you're 16
here in europe 18 and uh two years later
you can uh walk around with a gun open
carry uh without license even now um
you can hide your gun in some states and
don't even need a license for that um
you know it
makes no sense for for europeans or for
probably other people around the world
it's not fathomable yeah we hear from a
lot of viewers in the us too they they
don't understand this either
republican senators
they are insisting that any legislation
include funding for increasing security
at schools i mean we're looking at
schools
allegated
communities do u.s parents do they want
this
i don't know i can't
i don't think so i have talked to a few
parents who said this is ridiculous i
don't need i don't need to be my school
where my kids go my elementary school my
middle school my high school would be
for knox
on the other hand there are people who
are in support of this who say like you
know what and this is this old
good
put more guns in in the good guys hands
right
a resource officer fully armed at every
school
metal detectors on the teachers
fans around it
what have you they are there is a
segment of people in the united states
who say yeah okay if that's necessary
two protect my second amendment right
that anybody can
you know have the right any american has
the right to bear arms then so be it but
i would say that in the metropolitan
area the urban areas progressive
democrat
areas
there's a staunch opposition against
this of course yeah
all right our correspondent stephan
simon is in washington helping us
understand the
problem with guns in america stefan
thank you